train Services have resumed at the site
of India's worst rail disaster in 20
years preliminary reports suggest a
signaling system error caused the
multi-train Collision that killed 275
people on Friday but authorities have
launched a criminal investigation in
ballastor in eastern India umik also
Sharif met families looking for answers
after searching hospitals and morgues
Muhammad ashrafil is hoping to find his
missing nephew at this makeshift camp in
balasor
22 year old Muhammad voted the howrah
express one of the trains that collided
on Friday
I am running around in circles looking
for information the officials want me to
accept a body with a disfigured face as
my nephew how can they confirm this I
have been calling all the helpline
numbers there's no help now they want me
to go to another city to check the MOG I
don't have the money
there were six of them on the train we
live in the same place they were
supposed to go to Chennai we found four
of them in hospital but can't find the
other two
the government is under pressure to
provide answers Railways Minister
Ashwini vaishnav says a signaling error
cost the pile up
it is about the point machine and
electronic interlocking the change in
the electronic interlocking caused this
accident and whoever did it and whatever
other reasons will be known after the
investigation
the Army police and Railway workers have
joined teams from the adisha state
disaster management Agency on the ground
as the focus shifts from rescue mission
to clean up operation
India's Railway network is extensive
more than 12 million people commute by
train every day
to reduce travel times a new
japanese-funded bullet train is
scheduled to start running in 2026.
well let's go live now to Cole soon
she's in the regional capital
and she's outside a hospital morgue
because what's the situation there at
the morgue first of all
well Laura I'm at The olinier Institute
of Medical Sciences in bourbonnaisure
it's about 200 kilometers from balisol
where the accident took place now right
after the accidents nearly about 200
bodies were brought here because the
more this place has two mugs and the
bodies were brought here so this has a
lot of activity their ambulances behind
me and their family is waiting for the
bodies of their loved ones to be handed
over to them for those families it's
still a closure there are many other
families who are just inquiring looking
at cruising pictures trying to identify
their loved ones so many families still
looking to find those missing people
there's a police camp here police is
helping them and this is the point at
this entrance where humans just become
numbers because officials from inside
coming out and saying body number 36
body number 54 and the families have
been given these numbers and they have
to come and collect the bodies and take
them away it's just hard to speak to
anybody here we just so a father from
Bihar who lost two of his sons and he's
picked up the bodies and he's heading
back home to his wife who's alone at
home waiting to see her son's life but
he's bringing them dead it's an
absolutely tragic situation tell us more
about the direction that the
investigation is taking because it's now
becoming a criminal inquiry
well yes the railway Minister did say
there is an interlocking problem that's
what he said yesterday
but he's also said he recommends a
Central Bureau of Investigation uh
investigation investigating this entire
accident well the accident is is huge
because it didn't involve just one train
derailing it involved two-packed
passenger trains a good train so
essentially three trains coming together
a massive collision and we're seeing the
numbers of the Dead uh since Friday so
there are answers the government is
under pressure so they're looking for
answers but having said that I was
looking at a tweet from a railway
official who has raised questions about
the safety of the signaling system so
it's not like they have no questions
that have been raised to say India has a
very busy Railway Network we have about
30 million people take trains every day
travel the length of breath of the
country and we have thousands of friends
one crash like this raises questions
about the safety and the functional
system of an overworked Network oh okay
um Sharif thanks very much for bringing
us all the latest there from Eastern
India